[Applaus]
[Musik]
Russlands Invasion der Ukraine verändert
nicht nur den geo-unsicherheitspolitik
und Weltsicht Europas radikal sondern
auch jene Russlands und diese neue
Realität wird sich mit der Zeit immer
mehr bemerkbar machen und längst haben
wir euch in einem Video hier auf
visualpolitik berichtet wie die Sanktion
gegen Russland viele der Ziele die sie
anstreben erreichen
in der Tat ist Russland ein quantitativ
betrachtet dass am stärksten
sanktionierte Land der Welt konkret
begingen die Russen das Jahr 2023 mit
sage und schreibe 13.6 Sanktionen und
Beschränkungen alle Art und zwar gegen
die russischen Stadt die Unternehmen des
Landes und viele kriminale Oligarchen
fast 11.000 dieser Sanktionen wurden
dabei erst nach dem Überfall auf die
Ukraine am 24 Februar 2022 verhängt zum
Vergleich der Iran das am
zweithäufigsten sanktionierte Land der
Welt muss mit etwas über 4000 Sanktionen
und Beschränkungen klarkommen weiß
Syrien und Nordkorea sind es 2600
respektive 2100
[Musik]
aber damit nicht genug die westlichen
Volkswirtschaften und die meisten
Verbündeten der Ukraine haben
gigantische Anstrengungen unternommen um
nach und nach alles loszuwerden was aus
Russland kommt Gas Öl Oligarchen Geld
Touristen selbst russisches Sperrholz
steht auf der tabuliste ja fast alles
außer einer gewichtigen Sache den
weiträumigen Bereich der riesigen
russischen Nuklearindustrie
und für die gibt es einen kurzen und
prägnanten Namen RAS Atom unter diesem
firmenlabel ist in Russland alles
zusammengefasst was mit Atomenergie Uran
und Radioaktivität zu tun hat dieser
gewaltige Industriekonzern in Besitz des
russischen Staates ist vorerst von
Sanktionen verschont geblieben und das
hat einen Grund einen sehr guten Grund
heraus Atom wird geschont weil es Dinge
im Angebot hat die momentan viel
schwieriger zu ersetzen sind als banale
Kohlenwasserstoffe trotz enorme
Anstrengungen diese Lenski und um die
Uhr unternommen hat um seine Verbündeten
dazu zu drängen raus Atom ebenfalls auf
die Sanktionslisten zu setzen ist eben
dies bisher nicht gelungen 9 Januar 2023
Ukraine erwartet dass die EU Russlands
Ross Atom in die nächsten Sanktion
einzieht fünf Wochen darauf kamen die
eindeutige und ernüchternde antwortete
EU
[Musik]
16 Februar 2023 EU-Kommission lässt
Pläne für atomsanktionen gegen Russland
fallen die Europäische Kommission hat
ihre Pläne aufgegeben den russischen
Nuklearsektor oder seine Vertreter in
ihrem nächsten Sanktionspaket zu
sanktionieren die eu-exekutive hatte den
EU-Ländern zunächst mitgeteilt dass sie
versuchen würde das Sanktion gegen
Russland Zivil Nuklearsektor zu
verhängen aber dieser Plan ist
gescheitert ein EU-Diplomat sagte es ist
traurig was den nuklearen Teil angeht
hat uns niemand gesagt dass das nicht
okay ist oder ein Problem darstellen
wird deshalb sind wir überrascht während
der Westen die Zusammenarbeit selbst mit
staatlichen russischen Hochschulen und
mit Forschungsinstituten in garantiert
nicht kriegswichtigen Bereichen wie
Medizin oder Astronomie brutal auf Eis
gelegt hat darf Russland staatseigener
Atombranche munter weiter global
Wirtschaften warum aber um Himmels
willen ist das so gehört etwas zur
russischen Opposition oder spendet die
russische Nuklearbranche ihre Export
Erlöse etwa an die notleidende Ukraine
statt Putin für die Finanzierung seines
Krieges zur Verfügung zu stellen nun
keineswegs in Wahrheit ist das genaue
Gegenteil der Fall das ist umso
erstaunlicher wenn man bedenkt um welche
Art von verbrecherkonzern es sich
handelt sogar im Vergleich zu Gastraum
und Rassen eine ganz eigene Kategorie
und was genau wird damit meinen werden
wir euch in diesem Video zeigen aber
Moskaus Atom Gigant ist praktisch das
einzige russische Unternehmen von dem
wir sagen können das ist in seinem
Sektor wirklich mit den besten der Welt
mithalten kann sei es in Bezug auf
Technologie Wettbewerbsfähigkeit Kosten
oder Qualität Russland
atomenergiebranche ist also eine große
Ausnahme in der russischen
Industrielandschaft denn die ist ja um
es offen zu sagen eher von Ineffizienz
übermäßiger Korruption und
technologischen Rückstand gegen gewähren
westlichen pontos gekennzeichnet an
dieser Stelle muss ich euch allerdings
warnen heute müsst ihr starke Nerven
mitbringen denn vielen dürfte die
kritische Lage und der Horror der sich
hinter dem Namen heraus Atom
mittlerweile verbirgt im wahrsten Worten
in den Magen falls ihr es aber bis zum
Ende dieses Videos durchhalten solltet
werdet ihr genau verstehen warum dies
eines unserer düstersten Videos ist und
wieso ausgerechnet der Staatskonzern
raus Atom das geschafft hat woran das
prom und rasiert gescheitert sind eine
extrem kritische Abhängigkeit des
Westens von Russland zu erzeugen aber
der Reihe nach klären wir erst einmal
ein paar harmlos klingende fragen was
ist raus Atom eigentlich was macht man
da genau warum wurden doch keine
Sanktionen gegen das Unternehmen
verhängt und könnte sich das ändern oder
andersherum gefragt welche Rolle spielt
die Nuklearindustrie im politischen
wirtschaftlichen und militärischen
Gefüge von Putins Russland und wie
könnte sich der besten aus der
Abhängigkeit von raus Atom befreien
warum sagen wir Ross Atom sei ein wahrer
konzerndes horos sozusagen Potenz
Umbrella Corporation in diesem Video
werden wir all diese Fragen und noch ein
paar mehr beantworten und zwar gleich
nach der kurzen und knackigen
Werbebotschaft unseres Sponsors blink
ist denn die Berliner Firma blinkist hat
mit ihrem Beitrag nicht nur das heutige
Video möglich gemacht nein wir selbst
nutzen Ihre App auch um täglich unseren
eigenen Wissenshorizont zu erweitern
vielleicht fragt ihr euch ja manchmal
wie wir es schaffen so viel Wissen aus
verschiedenen Bereichen miteinander in
unseren Videos zu verknüpfen nun der
Schlüssel dazu ist vor allem lesen lesen
und manchmal auch hören artikelanalysen
Videos Podcast und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagen wissen das notwendig ist um
diese Information zu einem Gesamtbild
verknüpfen zu können aber was wenn man
gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so viele
verschiedene Bücher zu lesen nun genau
dann ist man bei blinkist Gold richtig
denn es hilft nicht nur einfach Zeit zu
sparen seine motiviert auch noch durch
die unterhaltsame Aufmachung mehr zu
lesen blinkt ist bringt das Wichtigste
aus mehr als 5000 Sachbüchern und
Podcast auf dein Handy und dann erlebst
du ein ungeahnten wissensbuchst anstatt
Stunden in die Lektüre eines Buches zu
stecken und es dann vielleicht gar nicht
zu Ende zu lesen siehst du dir einfach
in null Komma nichts die immer sehr
angenehm und locker geschriebene blinkt
ist Version rein dabei merkt man gleich
dass da echte Profis unter Talente am
Werk sind stell dir vor wir würden einen
wertvolles aber langes Buch in eine
knackiges und leicht verdauliches
visualpolitikvideo Gießen nun genau das
macht blinkist ich liebe zum Beispiel
populärwissenschaftliche Bücher über das
Weltall als ich jedoch das Buch des
tiktokers Niklas colorz vom Big Bang
quer durch die Weltgeschichte bis zum
Ende des Universums sah war ich zunächst
skeptisch ob es mir wirklich meine Zeit
wert sein sollte ich meine einerseits
erschien mir der Inhalt schon reizvoll
aber ein Buch von einem tiktoker tja
blinkist hat mir die Entscheidung
wesentlich erleichtert da ich nur 21
Minuten investieren musste um
herauszufinden ja das Buch ist
interessant und es macht Spaß ein
anderes Beispiel sind Bücher von Autoren
mit denen man vielleicht nicht einer
Meinung ist womit aber kann man sein
Horizont besser erweitern als mit
Informationen die eben nicht aus der
eigenen Bubble stammen mir ist z.B das
Buch kein Kapitalismus ist auch keine
Lösung der ehemaligen passautoren Ulrike
Herrmann aufgefallen auch hier habe ich
mir gesagt die das ist ja nicht gerade
mein Leib und magenblatt präsenten auf
Amazon haben das Buch auch dafür
kritisiert langatmig zu sein muss ich
mir das also wirklich antun andererseits
hat mich schon interessiert was da drin
steht und dank der fesselnd
geschriebenen linkes Fassung konnte ich
innerhalb von nur 25 Minuten
herausfinden dass dieses Werk zumindest
in der blinkist Fassung mein Horizont
durchaus bereichern konnte wichtiges
Wissen dass ich ohne blinkist sicher
verpasst hätte kurz gesagt diese App
wird mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit auch
dein Leben bereichern egal für welches
Thema du dich gerade interessierst die
Auswahl und das Spektrum sind wirklich
riesig von Finanzen über Wissenschaft
Politik Karriere bis zu den klassischen
Ratgeber Themen um sein Leben zu
optimieren aber man kann mit blinkist
nicht nur sich selbst sondern auch seine
Lieben bereichern es hat nämlich vor
kurzem eine ganz neue Funktion namens
blinkist Connect eingeführt damit kann
man einen blinkist Premium Abo auf zwei
verschiedenen Kunden nutzen und zwar
ohne zusätzliche Kosten und das ist noch
nicht alles visualpolitik Zuschauer
bekommen über den Link in der
Beschreibung nicht nur zwei
Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von einer
sondern obendrein noch einen Rabatt von
25%, also zöger oder nicht besorg dir
jetzt gleich die kostenlose 7 Tage
Testversion über den Link unter diesem
Video und fangen dann gleich damit an
deinen Wissenschaft zu bereichern so und
nun lasst uns schnell wieder zur
Beantwortung unserer brennenden Fragen
schreiten wie mächtig ist das Reich von
Ross Atom und wie kann sich der Besten
aus seiner Abhängigkeit lösen um es mit
Sanktion belegen zu können aufgepasst
strahlendes Kind
wie die meisten von euch wohl wissen
folgte auf den Zusammenbruch des
objektunion 1991 eine langjährige tiefe
Krise in der es zu einem massiven
wirtschaftlichen und industriellen
Eindruck kam der Nuklearsektor war dabei
natürlich keine Ausnahme ungeachteter
Tatsache dass sich so wird Union ein
große Player in der zivilen Kernenergie
war in der UdSSR wurde z.B das erste
Atomkraftwerk der Welt errichtet das
realstrom ins Netz einspeiste das
geschah schon entfernen ja 1954 zwar
aber das Kernkraftwerk in urbanien mit
einer Leistung von 5 Megabyte eher
winzig aber es schrieb Geschichte und es
war der Anfang eines ziemlich
erfolgreichen und eindrucksvollen Weges
anschließend haben die Sowjet mehr als
60 Atomreaktoren entworfen und gebaut
die über das ganze Land und den Rest des
kommunistischen Blocks verteilt worden
auf diese Weise erwarten sie bedeuten
und einen guten Ruf nun ja zumindest bis
ihnen 1986 das Atomkraftwerk
tschernobyll um die ohrenflug dieser
katastrophaler Atomunfall gilt ja heute
in gewisser Weise als Medizin das etwas
mega faul war im vermeintlich so soliden
Sowjet reich und fünf Jahre nach dem GAU
war die Sowjetunion Geschichte fakt ist
das mit den Zusammenbruch der
planwirtschaftlichen UdSSR auch das
gesamte industrielle Gefüge des Staates
zusammenbrach einige damals durchaus
starke russische Industriebranchen haben
sich im anbrechenden Kapitalismus nie
wieder erholt zum Beispiel der Bau von
Verkehrsflugzeugen andere schafften es
sich zu berappeln aber auf einem viel
niedrigeren Niveau als die westliche
Konkurrenz Stichwort Autoindustrie und
wieder andere wurden vom russischen
Staat behutsam wieder aufgepäppelt ist
da das war bei heraus Atom der Fall
Wladimir Putin selbst machte es sich zu
einem persönlichen Anliegen die
Atomindustrie wiederzubeleben zu diesem
Zweck erließ er 2006 ein Gesetz mit dem
ein langfristiger strategischer Rahmen
für den Nuklearsektor geschaffen werden
sollte und kurz darauf im Jahr 2007 wo
Putin höchstpersönlich rosa Tom als
staatliches Unternehmen aus der Taufe
hinter dieser Entscheidung stand die
Sorge der russischen Regierung über eine
immer größer werdende Kluft zwischen
Stromangebot und Nachfrage mit anderen
Worten Ross Atom sollte Russland
strumpfheit ein für alle Mal lösen und
so verhindern dass diese die Wirtschaft
weiterhin hemmt außerdem war Russland in
den 1990er Jahren vom internationalen
kernenergiemarkt ausgeschlossen weil es
keinen adäquaten Ansprechpartner
vorweisen konnte und das meine Lieben
Zuschauer war wirklich ein heftiger
Schlag ins Kontor denn von Anfang der
90er bis Mitte der 2000er Jahre wurden
weltweit mehr als 100 Atomreaktoren
gebaut Russland war während dieser
ganzen Zeit nicht in der Lage sich am
Bau und der Planung auch nur eines
einzigen von ihnen zu beteiligen mit
anderen Worten
Moskau wurde klar dass es sich eine
riesiges Geschäft im Energiesektor
entgehen ließ
damals war man in Russland noch ziemlich
flexibel und reformfreudig und deshalb
wurden ohne langes Palaver Nägel mit
Köpfen gemacht mit solider finanzieller
Unterstützung des russischen Staates
wurden auf Basis der bisherigen
staatlichen atomenergieagentur etwa 350
Strukturen unter dem neuen Dach
zusammengefasst Atomkraftwerke
Forschungsinstitute orange-fabriken für
Atomwaffen und Brennelemente und sogar
Russlands weltweit einzigartige Flotte
von atoma angetriebenen Eisbrecher war
der mastermann dieser Mission
tatsächlich ist er ist der bis heute
entscheidet wer in diesem Unternehmen
etwas zu sagen hat in früheren Videos in
denen es darum ging warum Russland am
Kapitalismus gescheitert ist und seine
Rüstungsindustrie nicht sehr
leistungsstark haben wir euch erklärt
wieso eine derartige Konsolidierung
ganze Branchen zu staatsmonopolen
hochproblematisch ist denn in den
meisten Fällen haben diese teils
planwirtschaftlichen Konzepte nicht zum
Erfolg geführt ich werde euch die Videos
natürlich verlinken damit ihr die
genauen Gründe erfahrt im Falle der
Nuklearbranche lief es jedoch anders
hier ist Putin s Plan aufgegangen
deine fakt ist die russische Kernenergie
hat mit dieser konzerngründung einen
gewaltigen Schritt nach vorne gemacht
und es heute eine der wichtigsten
internationalen Akteure im
kernenergiesektor ihr wollt es genau
wissen bitteschön von den 53
Atomreaktoren die Mitte 2022 weltweit im
Bauwagen befinden sich 20 Projekte unter
der Ägide von Ross Atom und 17 davon
entstehen außerhalb Russlands mit
anderen Worten wir sprechen hier von
einem Marktanteil von fast 40 % auf
Frankreich und Südkorea errichten
Reaktoren in anderen Ländern aber sie
sind jeweils nur an ein paar Projekten
beteiligt und das ist noch nicht alles
in vielen Fällen ist das russische
Unternehmen auch für die Wartung
Überwachung von Atomreaktoren mit
russischer Technologie auf der ganzen
Welt verantwortlich wir sprechen hier
von etwa einem Fünftel der fast 450 in
Betrieb befindlichen Reaktoren mit
anderen Worten können mit Funk und Recht
behaupten dass das Atom in den 15 Jahren
seines Bestehens geschafft hat den
international wenn schon nicht zu
dominieren so doch zumindest ist ein
wichtigste Akteur zu werden die Russen
sind hyperkompetitiv niemand in der oh
ICD kann mit ihrem Angebot mithalten
überrascht dann wartet es kommt noch
dicker wir fangen gerade erst an
denn der Grund warum der besten rossatom
nicht sanktioniert hat kann nicht nur
der Export von Atomreaktoren sein
schließlich haben die USA keinen
einzigen russischen Atomreaktor in
Betrieb und in weiten Teilen Europas
wurde die kämmerenergie auch jahrelang
an den Rand gedrängt und jetzt wo sie
zumindest mancherorts in Europa ein
Comeback erlebt sind die meisten
Anbieter von nuklear Technologie dort
westliche Staaten Russland spielt nur
einen Nebenrolle warum in aller Welt
wird Ross Atom also nicht sofort
sanktioniert was befindet sich da noch
im Spiel dass diese Möglichkeit momentan
gar nicht erst auf den Tisch kommt nun
hier kommt der vielleicht
interessanteste Teil der ganzen
Geschichte passt gut auf
hurra an made in Russia
die finanzsanktion und Beschränkungen
für technologielieferungen wurden sehr
schnell verhängt bei russischem Öl und
Gas brauchte man etwa ein dreiviertel
Jahr um die lieferinfrastruktur
umzustellen aber auch dort fließt jetzt
nichts mehr zum Zeitpunkt der Erstellung
dieses Videos hat der Ross Anton es
jedoch geschafft jeglichen
Einschränkungen für sein Geschäft zu
entgehen dafür muss es natürlich eine
Erklärung geben und das tut es auch der
russische Atomkonzern plant und baut
nicht nur Atomreaktoren sondern er
Reichert auch Uran an denn erinnert ihr
euch doch an die Meldung vom Anfang
dieses Videos
16 Februar 2023 EU-Kommission lässt
Pläne für Atom Sanktion gegen Russland
fallen ein EU-Diplomat sagte es ist
traurig was den nuklearen Teil angeht
hat uns niemand gesagt dass das nicht
okay ist oder ein Problem darstellen
wird deshalb sind wir überrascht okay
aber wer oder was hat diese Diplomaten
konkret dermaßen überrascht
Ungarn lässt das nicht durchgehen da ihr
Atomkraftwerk von Ross Atom betrieben
wird und 50% der Energieversorgung des
Landes abdeckt so hochrangiger
EU-Diplomat auch Frankreich hat
Zurückhaltung gefordert ein Beamter des
französischen Wirtschaftsministeriums
erklärte Reportern Anfang der Woche dass
viele Atomkraftwerke Brennstoff aus
russischer Energie verwenden ah da liegt
also der Hund begraben nicht nur das
kleine enforte riebele Ungarn blockiert
sondern auch der europäische
atomstrom-riese denn sowohl Frankreich
ist von der Energie aus russischen
Brennstäben abhängig als natürlich auch
Deutschland wo ohne russischen
nuklearstrom ebenfalls die Lichter
ausgehen würden die folgende Grafik
illustriert noch mal den ganzen Umfang
der Misere
obwohl es in diesem Sektor auch große
westliche Anbieter gibt ist eras-aton
mit rund 30% der Produktion und fast der
Hälfte der globalen Kapazität der
weltweit größte Produzent von
angereicherten urananen an dieser Stelle
ist es vielleicht notwendig zu erklären
dass man die Uran Erzförderung von der
Produktion angereicherten Urans
unterscheiden muss wohlgemerkt Russland
ist bei der Förderung des Rohstoffs gar
nicht mal vorne dabei wenn das meiste
Uran fördert Kasachstan mit mehr als 41%
des weltweiten Bedarfs gefolgt von
Australien mit 13% und Kanada mit 8%
Russland kommt erst unter ferner liefen
hinter Usbekistan allerdings stellte
Uran Abbau nur eine Phase im Prozess der
kernenergieerzeugung da und
verarbeitetes kann nicht als Kernreaktor
Brennstoff verwendet werden das Herz
muss raffiniert werden um einen
Konzentrate Schwermetall den sogenannten
Yellowcake herzustellen dieser kann dann
in Uran hexaflorid Gas umgewandelt
werden welches zur Trennung der
einzelnen Uranus bedient so dass eine
Anreicherung stattfinden kann und genau
bei diesen Prozessschritt kann Russland
glänzen zum Einsatz in Druck und
Siedewasserreaktoren wird das
angereicherte uranhexaflorid dann in
Brennelemente Fabriken erst zu Uranoxid
und schließlich zu fertigen
Brennelementen verarbeitet und auch
hierbei kontrolliert Russland 17 Prozent
des weltweiten Marktes für Brennelemente
nach eigenen Angaben von Ross Atom
werden 73 Atomreaktoren in 13
verschiedenen Ländern mit seinen
Brennstoff betrieben und wir reden hier
nicht nur über druckkraftwerke des
sowjetischer Bauart wie es sich zum
Beispiel noch in ungarischen oder der
Slowakei gibt 2021 lieferte Rosen z.B
auch fast ein Viertel des gesamten
kernbrennstoffs der von US
Kernkraftwerken verwendet wird dabei
wird geschätzt dass die Russen selbst in
einem Szenario eines angestrebten
Lieferantenwechsels kurz bis
mittelfristig noch mindestens 15 % des
Kuchen in den USA behalten werden und
dass meine Lieben Zuschauer liegt daran
dass ist ein sehr langer und
kostspieliger Prozess ist eine
Produktion von Kämpfen in vernünftigen
Umfang unsere vernünftigen Preisen in
den Gang zu bringen
traditionell ist moskausmarktanteil in
Europa auch nicht gerecht
die Russen liefern 26% des
angereicherten Urans und rund 20% des
gesamten in die EU importierten Urans
damit stehen sie auf dem alten Kontinent
auf Gleis 3 hinter Niger und Kasachstan
und deswegen sieht man tatsächlich immer
noch von Zeit zu Zeit russische
Frachtflugzeuge am europäischen Himmel
für sie gilt es ansonsten drakonische
Flugverbot für russische
Fluggesellschaften nicht denn wenn sie
nuklearen Brennstoff an Bord haben
können Sie frei einfliegen okay aber
warum ist das alles für uns offenbar so
wichtig dass Rosaton gegen westliche
Sanktion immun ist schließlich handelt
es sich dabei ja auch um einen für das
russische Militär unverzichtbaren
Staatskonzern nämlich für jeden Konzern
der für nichts weniger als die
Entwicklung und den Bau von Russlands ab
bombomben verantwortlich ist ja langsam
wird es verdammt knifflig und ich sage
euch das ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
also schnallt Euch jetzt noch mal gut an
strategischer Einfluss
an dieser Stelle dürfte es auch der
allerletzte begriffen haben rasatom ist
alles andere als eine kleine Klitsche
viel mehr handelt es sich um ein
riesiges Unternehmen mit 290.000
Beschäftigten 2021 vermeldete der
Konzern einen Rekordgewinn in Höhe von
20 Milliarden Dollar und nicht nur das
im selben Jahr hatte die Holding
Gesellschaft atomenergo prom in der ein
großer Teil der Rosaton Aktivitäten
zusammengefasst ist ein üppiges
Portfolio von Auslandsaufträgen im Wert
von fast 140 Milliarden Dollar die ist
in den nächsten 10 Jahren auszuführen
Geld und aufgepasst zwei dieser Verträge
zum Bau von Atomreaktoren wurden mit
NATO-Ländern geschlossen um welche es
sich handelt nun einmal dürfte erraten
27 August 2022 Ungarn treibt den Bau von
atomraktoren russische Bauart voran
trotzdem Krieg in der Ukraine werden die
Arbeiten am Standort Packs in den
kommenden Wochen beginnen so und ganz
Außenminister
30 Juli 2022 Russlands Ross Atom
unterzeichnet neuen Bauvertrag für
türkisches Atomkraftwerk die türkische
Regierung will den ersten Reaktor
insgesamt 4.800 Megawatt starken Anlage
noch vor den Parlamentswahlen im
nächsten Jahr in Betrieb nehmen
Präsident erdogan hat bereits angedeutet
dass die Türkei mit Russland beim Bau
von zwei weiteren Anlagen
zusammenarbeiten können könnte okay das
war wohl keine große Überraschung nicht
wahr die Auftraggeber sind just Ungarn
mit zwei neuen Reaktorblöcken und die
Türkei mit momentan vier also ihnen
beiden NATO-Staaten die nicht gerade auf
eine harten Konfrontation gehen bei
beiden akw-projekten handelt es sich
selbstverständlich um Grundpfeiler der
energiestrategien dieser beiden Länder
und sie stellen zusammen ein
Auftragsvolumen von über 30 Milliarden
Dollar da allein diese sattelstunde
zeigt dass der Bau und die dann
anschließende Jahrzehnte lange Wartung
der neuen Reaktoren das mit Abstand
lukrativste Geschäftsführer ist
im Vergleich dazu fällt das Geschäft mit
den Brennelementen geradezu in die
Kategorie Klinker Lätzchen die
jährlichen Importe von Uran und
Kernbrennstoff aus Russland durch die
Vereinigten Staaten und die Europäische
Union haben nämlich einen Gegenwert von
kaum einer Milliarde Dollar pro Jahr ja
das ist auch eine schöne Stange Geld
aber im Peanuts im Vergleich zu den fast
200 Milliarden Dollar die vor dem Krieg
in Form von Kohlenwasserstoffen aus
Russland importiert wurden und es reicht
auch nicht an das heran was raus Atom
mit seinen Reaktor und
Kraftwerksgeschäft verdient und ihr
denkt jetzt vielleicht könnte man rosa
Baum nicht mit Sanktion belegen um zu
verhindern dass der Konzern zumindest
keine neuen Reaktoren und Kraftwerke
bauen kann während man bei ihm
notgedrungen eben weiterhin Uran und
Kernelemente einkauft zumindest so lange
bis man diese Lieferungen nicht durch
andere Quellen ersetzen kann nun ja im
Prinzip könnte der Westen das so machen
und es würde Ross Atom heftig schaden
aber das Kosten Nutzen Verhältnis wäre
für die Alliierten grotten schlecht man
würde mit diesen Sanktion extrem viel
riskieren und sich eventuell mehr
Schaden als den Kremmen es würde sich
hierbei wirklich sich um
kontraproduktive Sanktionen handeln denn
russisches Öl und Gas ließen sich viel
leichter und schneller ersetzen als es
bei den Brennelementen der Fall wäre und
da es im Vergleich zum Ölgeschäft auch
wie gesagt um viele kleinere Beträge und
wesentlich geringere Gewinnspannen für
den Kreml geht würde es sich um eine
dermaßen langfristige Maßnahme handeln
dass sie unter Garantie erst in vielen
Jahren Potenzen Nachfolger treffen würde
und angesichts dieser schlechten
Ausgangslage für den Westen muss man
sich eigentlich eher etwas anderes
fragen wieso nutzen diese Situation
nicht aus um den Westen zu erpressen
denn es gibt gleich zwei gewichtige
Risiken zu bedenken
erstens könnte ein solcher Schritte auf
einem so begrenzten Markt mit wenigen
Anbietern dazu führen dass Russland von
sich aus dieser Einnahmen opfert einfach
nur um im Westen einen akuten Mangel an
Kernbrennstoff auszulösen denn das
könnte schließlich in Nordamerika und
Europa zu echten versorgungsen für die
Atomkraftwerke führen und das in einer
Zeit ohne hin hohe Energiepreise und
knapp Reserven
und zweitens gibt es global auch nicht
so viele Anbieter von Kerntechnik für
moderne Kraftwerke mit anderen Worten
ein Importverbot für diese Technologien
würde wahrscheinlich zu einem Engpass
bei den Kapazitäten der zivilen
Atomindustrie in Ländern wie den USA
Frankreich und Südkorea führen der die
weltweite Energieversorgung gefährden
würde das wäre alles andere als
wünschenswert in einer Epoche in der
aufgrund der endlichen
Kohlenwasserstoffe und der angestritten
Erfüllung der Klimaziele die größte
Elektrifizierung in der Geschichte der
Menschheit erwartet wird über diese
große globale Energiewende haben wir
hier auf visualpolitik und auf unserem
Schwester Kanal visual economie übrigens
schon genauer berichtet ihr findet die
Videos unten verlinkt
die Realität sieht also so aus dass der
Westen sehr vorsichtig mit Sanktion
gegen Ross Atom sein muss und genau
deshalb ist Ross Atom bisher ungeschoren
davongekommen aber wieso dreht Putin den
Spieß dann nicht um und stoppt die
Uranlieferungen an den westlichen Feind
nun auch er weiß dass er mit dem
atomaren Feuer spielen würde denn damit
würde er den übrigen Kunden von Ross
Atomuhr zeigen dass Russland auch auf
diesen Sektor ein unzuverlässlicher
Lieferant ist und diese könnten sich
dann langfristig von rostab darauf
abwenden und ihre Nukleartechnik Liebe
in den USA und der EU einkaufen aber
Moment mal habe ich vorhin nicht gesagt
dass die ja selbst nicht genug haben und
eben deshalb von Russland abhängig sein
nun ja habt ihr etwa geglaubt dass man
in Brüssel und Washington und tätig die
Däumchen dreht und abwartet bis Putin
den uranhahn abdreht nein ganz und gar
nicht denn an dieser Stelle kommt der
große Plot fest wie beim Gas und Öl
haben sowohl die Vereinigten Staaten als
auch die Europäische Union bereits Pläne
ihre Produktion von angereicherten Uran
Brennstoff für Kraftwerke zu erhöhen und
somit auch in diesen Bereich ihrer
Abhängigkeit von kremlikator für immer
adieu und bei beizusagen die USA
verstärken ihre Bemühungen die
Abhängigkeit von russischem
Kernbrennstoff zu beenden das Weiße Haus
räumte Entwicklung inländische Uran
einreichungskapazitäten Priorität ein
und geht davon aus dass wichtige
Gesetzgeber mit ziehen werden damit bis
2025 ein Plan für die
brennstoffherstellung umgesetzt werden
kann
Kasachstan bietet Europa die Chance sich
das russische Uran abzugewöhnen die
Kasachen verfügen über riesige
unerschlossene Uran vorkommen die ihren
ohnehin schon großen Marktanteil noch
weiter steigern könnten außerdem
verfassen über große Oberflächen nahe
Uran vorkommen die durch die Injektion
von Flüssigkeiten unter die
Erdoberfläche ähnlich wie beim Fracking
kostengünstig abgebaut werden können
aber die europäischen Pläne russisches
Uran und russische Uran Aufbereitung zur
boykottieren stehen vor weiteren
Problemen wenn die zahlreichen
Hindernisse beim Transport bei der
logistischen Umstellung und nicht zu
vergessen in der Politik jedoch
überwunden werden können wäre gestern
Angesicht seines Uran Reichtums in einer
idealen Lage um für die nächsten
Jahrzehnte Europas wichtigste und
zuverlässigste uranlieferant zu werden
Kernenergie ist Emery powering-plan der
EU enthalten die Europäische Kommission
hat den Repower eu-plan der darauf
abzielt die Abhängigkeit der EU von
russischen fossilen Brennstoffen schnell
zu verringern formell angenommen der
Plan unterstreicht die Bedeutung
koordinierter Maßnahmen zur Verringerung
der Abhängigkeit von russischen
Kernmaterialien und Dienstleistungen des
brennstoffkreislaufs aber solange das
eben nicht der Fall ist bleibt raus ab
Tom natürlich von entscheidender
Bedeutung für den reibungslosen Betrieb
viele westliche AKWs eine reales Risiko
besteht nun allerdings darin dass die
westliche Abhängigkeit ist raus Atom
ermöglicht so eine Art sanktionsumgebung
Straße zu werden über die Technologien
sanktionsgüter und Finanzen nach
Russland fließen die letztendlich den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine dienen
[Musik]
und noch schlimmer Ross Abkommen hat
sich auch selbst aktiv an der Invasion
der Ukraine und wohl auch an kriegsver
Menschen beteiligt denn im Auftrag der
russischen Regierung ist der Konzern der
derzeitige Betreiber des besetzten
kernkraftwerksaporisch ja und solange
die Okkupation dieses Gebiets anhält de
facto dessen Hausherr und bei dieser
ukrainischen Anlage mit sechs Reaktoren
handelt es sich um nichts Geringeres als
das größte Atomkraftwerk Europas seit
Beginn seiner Besetzung wurden die
Anlage nach Lust und launendes Cremes
rauf und runtergefahren um die Moral der
Ukraine zu untergraben und sie daran zu
hindern durch den Export von Strom an
ihre europäischen Nachbarin Geld zu
verdienen diese Energie Terror gegen
Europa und die ukrainische Bevölkerung
ist jedoch nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
denn der Name Ross Atom wird wohl in die
Geschichte eingehen mit
verbrecherkonzernen wie EG fahren Flick
und Krupp
das Loch grauenvolle Berichte über die
russische Besatzung im ukrainischen
Atomkraftwerk vom Generaldirektor bis
hinunter zu den Arbeitern berichten alle
dass sie entführt und den unterirdischen
Zellen festgehalten wurden wo sie oft
geschlagen oder gefoltert wurden die
Seele einiger Menschen wurde gebrochen
pedrokortchen der Leiter der
ukrainischen sagte dass er raus
atombeamte nicht in die Festnahme von
Mitarbeitern involviert sein ihnen aber
mitgeteilt hätten wenn ihr nicht zu uns
kommen wollt verlasst das Werk aber wir
können nicht sicher sein dass euch
draußen nichts schlimmes passiert
Mitarbeiter des Kernkraftwerks die ist
aus der Internierung geschafft haben
berichten dass eine Einheit des FSB
unterirdische Gefängnisse in der Nähe
der Anlage betreibt in denen sie mit
Gewehrkolben und Schlagstöcken auf die
Inhaftierten Arbeiter einschlugen ihnen
in die Füße und ellbogenschossen ihnen
das Essen vorenthielten und Elektroden
an Ohren und Dingen anbrachten einige
wurden in einer unterirdischen Anlage
festgehalten und gefolter die die Russen
das Loch nannten ein unter Wasser
Techniker andre und charok der in diesem
Gefängnis ins Koma geprügelt wurde stark
später mehr als 200 Beschäftigte wurden
festgenommen und dutzende werden noch
vermisst
man muss sich das mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen hier geht es um hunderte
unschuldiger Menschen die nur deswegen
gefangen gehalten und gefoltert werden
weil sie Fachkräfte sind die ein
Atomkraftwerk betreiben sollen das von
Ross Atom besetzt wird man setzt sie
unmenschlichen Qualen aus um sie dazu zu
zwingen das zu tun was ihnen die
eingerückten Rost atomanager Befehlen
saporizia ist damit eines der
Hauptargumente der ukrainische Regierung
bei der Forderung dieses Unternehmen so
schnell wie möglich zu sanktionieren
aber wie ihr schon gesehen habt die
Dinge sind hierbei nicht so einfach
Gerechtigkeit lässt sich leider nicht
immer sofort durchsetzen vor allem wenn
man es mit einem mächtigen Gegner zu tun
hat kurz um heraus Atom ist für Russland
viel mehr als nur eine Geldquelle es ist
eine wirtschaftliche und
energiepolitische Trumpfkarte von
strategischem wertvoller als Gastraum
und vielleicht sogar wichtiger als die
russische Armee und bei diesen zivilen
atomaren angucken hätte der Krämer im
Gegensatz zum militärischen die besseren
Karten in der Hand aber was meint ihr
glaubt ihr die USA und Europa täten doch
gut dran ihre Atomstromproduktion auf
Spiel zu setzen um heraus Atoms sofort
zu sanktionieren ist dieses Unternehmen
Putins letzter großer strategischer
Trumpf außerhalb des Schlachtfelds oder
tun alle Konfliktparteien gut daran vom
sensiblen zivilen atombereich lieber die
Finger zu lassen wie immer sind auf eure
Kommentare zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gebt uns bitte ein Like als mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert mit ihnen
darüber und vergiss bitte auch nicht das
aber mit glücklichen und keines unserer
Videos zu verpassen was ihr auch nicht
verpassen solltet ist das Angebot von
blinkist mit dem du zwei
Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von einer
bekommst und obendrein noch
fünfundzwanzig Prozent Rabatt holt euch
also jetzt die kostenlose 7 Tage
Testversion über den Link in der
Beschreibung oder diesen Video natürlich
freuen uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen Link dazu findet ihr in
der Beschreibung unter dem Video mach's
gut und bis bald
[Musik]